suppose i live with my college roommate
we have a script idea
and we are both writing it and we've
completed this amazing 100 page script
we're going to shop it around we're
friends so there's nothing to worry
about right
that's it's
and this is so common we i hate to say
it but
once or twice a year every year the
problem comes in because
it doesn't it doesn't happen until
one of two things either you can't sell
it so
one wants to change it dramatically the
other one doesn't
or you get an offer one wants to take it
one doesn't
it's that point in time and then
you don't have an agreement what do we
do who gets to decide
it's a mess there are there's an easy
collaboration agreement
with comments and the way the book is
set up
there's an email address where you just
type it in and you'll get a clean copy
word word version downloadable
that you can change and use and then you
just follow the book along with
how to use it because this this
book when it talks about contracts has a
lot of instructional boxes
that tell you how to use the contracts
that are in the book
at what point am i doing this
early very very when you guys are still
friends
and living together and loving each
other and loving the script
um you know we see it all the time and
people have interesting memories bad
memories different memories of what the
agreement was who created the storyline
who was the first person to come up with
this idea
and we could we have so many outlandish
things that come in the office i had a
guy who came in here one time
and he insisted that he created
the storyline and wasn't the writer he
worked with a friend who actually had
the experience in writing
but he basically created the entire
story and the other guy came in and said
absolutely not this was totally my thing
he came up with a little bit of an idea
i expanded it i wrote the script he gave
me a few notes that weren't even helpful
i mean the stories were night and day
and so had they initial
and they ended up actually just
scrapping the project it was essentially
they just burnt
the script they said forget it we're not
going to move forward with each other
um and there's there's no way we're
going to reconcile this
and had they just at the beginning put
together something simple something a
simple collaboration agreement or
something simple even by email saying
you know
i came up with this you came up with
this we're going to work together we're
going to be owners on this 50 50.
um since i have the experience more as a
producer i'm going to shop this and i'll
come to you with any sort of deals and
we'll make sure that we're both okay
with it
you know something very simple just that
outlines what will happen in success and
what will happen if one of us wants to
move on
what if somebody gets a full-time job
and they can't work on the script
anymore
so just to lay out those contingencies
even in a simple way is so important
and from another practical perspective
if the film does get sold
or somebody's interested in it they
don't want to deal with the drama
between the two writers
they want that result whose face whose
name is first
you know all of that kind of stuff they
want it settled otherwise they move on
to the next project because there
are a lot of scripts out there so even a
simple email exchange in the initial
beginning of forming the story idea
would have been
satisfactory yeah helpful you know how
sometimes it might have been completely
conclusive like this is the deal
in other circumstances that you might
say well there's seven other email
strings and look what we said over here
you know so there certainly could be
that
but it's always helpful to have at least
something in writing
a lot of people avoid it because they
want to
avoid some sort of conflict and when
people say that to me i said oh my gosh
you're going to avoid a conflict now to
cruise
but you're going to face it someday so
you don't want to put all the pro the
time and effort into writing a script
and then not know what you're going to
do with it decide that now
yeah decide it when you can say oh
okay that's the way you want to okay i
guess i don't want to write a script
with you
because that's a big commitment sure
people are making these commitments
all the time without an understanding
of how is it going to play out cause not
every
script gets immediately sold for a
million bucks and made into a film that
wins an academy award
they're actually scripts written that
that doesn't happen to
you learn a new thing every day yes how
does one have the talk
then with with a friend roommate
whatever
collaborators the question how does one
have the time yeah how do you do it in a
non-threatening way that's not like oh
hey my lawyer asked me to
send this to you and say how does
someone do it in a very sort of
easy going way eventually bringing out
some type of
contract but the first words out of your
mouth is
before we actually start writing okay
comma comma dot dot okay maybe we should
talk about the business side of our
relationship
period next sentence
like whose name will go first on the
script
or as one that's one issue that should
be solved
uh are we going to be 50 50 owners
just putting the questions there yeah
and it is i do understand it is
uncomfortable especially when you're
working with friends to
talk about those things but it's so
important and you can say i just read
this book clearance and copyright and it
suggested that we have this conversation
now
um you know and i think it can be do i
think it can be done in a way
because it's beneficial for both parties
you know you're not saying let's have
this conversation because i'm trying to
protect my interest
it's like let's have this conversation
because in the event we're lucky enough
for someone want to buy this
we need to have all these things worked
out so let's just work it out now
you know so if someone's response to
that which i've i've hear this
oh i'm totally cool i'm so easygoing
don't even worry about it
but yeah dot dot dot then you would
interject with
that sounds great so am i but let's just
get this
right and running okay that's right yeah
yeah i think he's just having that
conversation that can be a little bit
difficult but one that will be so much
more difficult and could potentially
ruin your project
down the road if you wait yeah and you
know if it turns out
that the two of you have a very
different idea
like oh yeah we'll write it together
we'll own it 50 50. but i get to make
all the decisions about
how it's exploited oh
can we talk about that no that's a
that's an absolutely
okay maybe i don't want to write this
script with you
and and then your your plate your life
is open for some other project that
where
the working relationship is better yeah
and that is a good point if you can't
have that conversation with the person
you're writing a script with
maybe you shouldn't be writing that
script with that person
you